a lot of students have issues when
they're refueling for the first time so
we'll have essentially an airliner full
of fuel hundreds of thousands of pounds
and you pull up behind it and it's
really easy to crash into it so a lot of
students are really nervous you know you
can reverse that stress by wiggling your
fingers wiggling your toes taking deep
breaths it really depends how much
oxygen demand you need but Fox breathing
five seconds in hold five seconds five
seconds out hold five seconds but the
big thing is just not hyperventilating
so trying to slow down your breathing as
much as possible and then lastly for me
it's literally expanding that tunnel
vision so looking out of the corner your
eyes it's called tunnel vision not just
because cognitively you're focused on a
single thing but your vision shrinks
down and that's a really important thing
when you're showing up at close air
support firefights the troops on the
ground are under a lot more stress than
you are so when we show up it's our job
to be able to make good decisions and to
be that calming Force that's detached
from what's going on in the ground